delicious
delicious happy Friday
everybody yeah right okay I get it I get
it you love me hope you had a nice
Thanksgiving I know I did those New York
pigeons are actually pretty
tasty now since it's a holiday weekend I
thought we'd keep things nice and light
so let's talk about the death of Western
Civilization
it's in trouble people yeah things in
the west these days are about as stable
as Chris Christie on an exercise
ball sadly most people either don't
realize it or they just don't care well
for anyone who doesn't care trust me
you're going to Care soon enough because
the guardian of Western values has
always been America but now not so much
let's face it we a nation that melts
down if our smartphone runs out of power
so look around yourself especially at
our young people people you see a nation
capable of standing up for itself
especially when it's run by a guy who
literally can't stand by
himself do you think do you still think
we're capable of safeguarding the system
that has cured more disease created more
wealth and lifted more people out of
poverty than any in human history or do
you see a system obsessed with dividing
US based on Grievances and pronouns do
you see leadership capable of protecting
Western values hell under these holes we
can't even protect deodorant and
toothpaste at a CVS let alone Western
Civilization now we got societal Decay
plus tooth decay like I said we're in
more trouble than day and I trying to
reach a
doorknob I know now before you accuse me
of being too pessimistic let me just say
the West has been tested before and
we've come through remember the movie
300 in 480 BC that's before Cable
Dana a small band of Greeks held off the
Persians invading from the east no
wonder they're so good at running a pack
Diner but Greek civilization survived
and their ideas of democracy and rights
became the foundation of Western Society
plus they gave us
Cojack more recently in 1940 when it
looked like the Nazis could take over
all of Europe it was the British who
stood up to them alone sound familiar to
what Israel is doing right now doesn't
it meanwhile the French bent over so
fast they strained their
croissants when the main British Army
was surrounded at Dunkirk Winston
Churchill gave one of the great speeches
of the 20th century rallying his Nation
so the Brits used anything that could
float to evacuate their boys across the
channel England survived until America
entered the war and the West tradition
of Freedom was rescued again compare
that to the American evacuation from
Afghanistan which made Dunkirk look like
a cruise on Royal Kore Caribbean here's
our Winston Churchill
today
yeah our only hope would be if the enemy
died
laughing Churchill said we shall fight
them in the streets and we have a
president who keeps losing his fight
with
gravity then there was the Cold War it
was of course Republican Ronald Reagan
who told the Soviets in Berlin this Mr G
off teared down this
wall when the wall and Soviet communism
fell our president didn't the West
survived once again for the host at
MSNBC however that day is still known as
black Thursday the point is there are
moments in history where things hang in
the balance and when these moments come
it takes courage it takes resolve and it
takes leadership to stand up for our way
of life doesn't it feel like we're in
such a moment the problem today is the
enemies within right now Hamas is guilty
of killing 32 Americans and holding at
least 10 more hostage yet across the
country in Dem run cities and colleges
Hamas are the heroes can we look this
challenge in the eye and face up to it
it's no accident that on our campuses
among the critical race theorists and
within the Legacy Media Israel was cast
as the aggressor almost before the first
female raver was raped and murdered
because to a generation of Young
Americans subjected to an education
system borrowed from the Soviets
Israel's main crime is being too
successful too modern too Western too
much like us the real oppressor so how
far has it gone well the new trend among
American women advocating for Hamas is
adopting Sharia law which would put them
back in the Dark Ages they're even
wearing the KNE cob let's hope this
catches on at the
[Laughter]
view
but but I'm sure the these women are
still counting on us to pay off their
college loan since I doubt the Taliban
will pick up the tab for their degrees
in women's studies so why is the most
successful Nation ever the guardian of
the most successful civilization ever
choosing to destroy itself from within
well put simply because it can it's
almost out of boredom here's the sports
analogy the US is like a football team
up by 35 points in the second half and
they start putting in scrubs and playing
that damn prevent defense and suddenly
they're losing our Elites don't have to
worry about enough food or a warm bed as
they've replaced patriotism with a
punitive ideology directed inward we
have a generation that sees everything
through the lens of power and it's
infecting everything each relationship
is now seen through the filter of the
oppressed versus the oppressor and you
know what side they put you on now they
got the kids who are so desperate for
relevance and identity they'll take on
any pose to convince themselves are cool
and hating America is their definition
of that is there hope sure as I've said
that West has come through before but
it's going to take effort we're pretty
short on Churchills and Reagans as we
overdose on
aoc's so if you're a parent think hard
about where your kids are going to
school make sure they understand that
America is unique in history and so are
the achievements and the freedoms of
Western Civilization because if you
leave education to the teachers union
the college professors the shrieking
non-binary activists when the time comes
don't expect the West to be rescued
again this time there's a good chance
America won't be
coming let's welcome tonight's
guest this is her last gig before she
returns to work at Santa's Workshop
co-host of America's Newsroom in the
five Dana
burrito his Anthony fouchy impression is
so good it'll make you sick sick actor
and standup comedian Tyler
fiser she loves to Surf and defend
American Turf Fox News contributor Tulsi
gabard and some say he's too handsome to
be a comedian and by some I mean me
comedian Jeff
D Dana how's that for an upbeat Friday
monologue huh it pretty good I I read a
whole article in the New York Times this
weekend though about how being hot in
comedy is becoming a thing yes it is I
don't know I wouldn't know saw that I
wouldn't know either I think okay but
but seriously I think that you are uh
hitting the nail on the head uh one
thing that's curious is you know young
people usually like to Rebel yeah and so
if they were rebelling against people
who are teaching them this nonsense they
would become Ultra patriotic right
they'd be like super Maga and like
wearing you know flying the American
flag right just to piss off their
parents and their teachers exactly but
what if they don't even have that
anymore what if the we've killed the
rebellious Spirit maybe we have I do
think that it's shocking these young
women who think that they would be
better off as Muslims I mean there's a
lot of them to we might be better off
because the roads would be
safer a sexist would say hey she said it
she said it that's called a joke
America hey I like this lady
yes I have a feeling Nick doollo gave
you that joke I don't know who you of
whom you speak um I think about these
young women like if they were in Israel
they would be in the reserves they would
be called up to fight for their country
yeah instead they're figuring out
they're fighting they have this whole
thing on social media they're fighting
with the hijab to try to figure out how
to put it on and then they have online
they're like oh no here do it this way
sweetheart like you're really going to
love I mean do you remember when we were
in the 70s you had to go to these
classes to avoid going into like weird
memberships of things right this is I
apparently they don't do that any longer
no no no in fact they push you right in
Tyler what do you think this is such a
setup why what do you think Trump would
say regarding the death of Western
Civilization would he think he could
save it well first I'm wondering if Dana
was talking about me being the hot
comedian in her Jeff I'm still
definitely beards are in dude Jeff's
just taller hotter me without a beard so
um frankly I think he would say excuse
me Greg I would think he would say we
have to get back to the American flag
because no think of it I walked down the
street I saw rainbow flags and the flags
of other countries right Jeff other
countries and I thought no frankly Dana
if adul if a alien landed in New York
City they think they landed in gay
Ukraine
frankly right
where are we we don't even know where we
are we're all mixed
[Applause]
up everyone has the same rights right
and I'm really am tired of seeing this
flurry of flags and at this point I
think it's Whoever has the most colorful
flag gets the celebratory you know March
yeah you know palestine's got a lot of
colors on their flag that's true we only
have three we got to do better RAC yeah
we're racist three racist colors the
most racist colors exactly Tulsi welcome
back um was that am I being too
pessimistic are you
optimistic uh not quite yeah uh I'm
trying to be in the positive spirit here
in the spirit of Thanksgiving to be
grateful for all that we have but but I
think your opening was was very cleare
eyed um you know I think what's
interesting here with with all of these
American women now converting to become
Muslim it's it's kind of the the latest
iteration of well how do I get that you
know Rebel super so-called Progressive
street cred immediately uh especially if
they're white they can't become black
people have tried that before and failed
yeah it's
coming so so you know for them to to go
and say okay well now I'm going to be a
Muslim then they get rid of all of their
white guilt immediately they get rid of
all that white privilege that they were
born with the things that they're
struggling with trying to deal with uh
and immediately become those
revolutionaries that they they seem to
be seeking but at the same time as
pointed out Dana not really seeming to
understand at all what it is they are
claiming to become uh nor the terrorist
radical islamist ideology that that
terrorist groups like Hamas uh espouse
and are trying to spread there is no
real housewives of Palestine what are
they going to
watch what are they going to watch what
am I going to watch I'd watch that
though I would definitely watch that
Jeff you and I would watch it together
am I is this typical like I could see
somebody looking at this go this is
typical hand ringing from a silver fox
you know an older dude looking down to
the generations nobody even said yeah
Greg you're Silver Fox shut up every I
was naughty and I said heck yeah what's
your take on this I mean I think it's
laughable I can't even every time it got
brought up it made me giggle just that
young women I went through the me too
movement as a bro you know I'm a
straight white guy that makes jokes
about women in my ACT I love women but
it's fun to tease them yeah fun to be a
little piggy in the mud I like it yeah
you know so I make jokes about women and
the whole me too movie was like ah his
comedy shouldn't he shouldn't say that
about a woman and then these same women
yeah want to convert to Islam yeah the
same women that were with their signs of
the me too are going now I'd like to be
M it's insane and even like they be like
free Gaz and like shut up lady but yeah
free Gaza that's what they're signing up
for they're actually I mean even even if
they aren't converting they're marching
alongside people that think of them as
inferior it's yeah they're saying Jeff
don't make jokes about us but we
shouldn't uh show our faces and we
should be treated as property and uh we
should be beaten with sticks if we say
things out of turn that's insane those
are the same people yeah it's crazy
makes no sense not very funny but it's
just saying that just means it's not it
actually isn't about ideology it's about
power it's about the need for power that
but also like you were saying that maybe
people rebel against what their parents
make them do
maybe we should be dragging these kids
you know over to the Middle East and we
should be bringing them to drag shows
you know then they'll go I hate drags
shows you know because their parents
forced it on them maybe yeah my parents
did that to me and it didn't
work just made you love heels yes hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else